if you've turned your tv to anything
besides netflix in the last few years
there's a good chance you've seen the at
t commercials featuring lily adams
a resourceful store employee since 2013
melania vine troop has played the
character in more than 40 tv spots for a
t
and for many avid viewers she's become
synonymous with the telecommunications
brand
so it was a welcome surprise when she
recently made a reappearance for an ncaa
march madness themed commercial
this time around we see lily hyping up
at t's 5g network to a march madness fan
every time the customer has a new
question they also have a new foam
finger
which lily can't help but point out is a
little bit weird
after she's answered all of the
questions of course you're very good at
whatever this is you flatter me the new
march madness ad fits right in with the
other lily spots
showcasing her quirky personality and
quick wit
coming in to get a deal that includes
existing customers is probably five
april we'll give him an even tricks what
it's
however fans may have noticed that in
this commercial
the character who can often be seen
roaming around in a t store
is stationed behind a desk with her body
mostly concealed
it turns out that concealing her body
was an intentional choice by vine troop
and she was more than willing to share
with fans why she'll continue to do so
for the time being
after receiving numerous questions about
why her body is hidden in the latest at
t commercials melania vine troop who
also voices squirrel girl in new
warriors
took to twitter to explain the decision
she wrote
well i direct the ads i place myself
like that
and it's because of the thousands of
unwelcome comments
i receive about my body you've lost the
privilege of looking at it
until i feel safe again this is not the
first time vine troop has directly
addressed the fact that she receives
unwanted comments about her body
last year she spoke out about the sexual
harassment she received online
which intensified after photos of
herself in college were spread around
during an instagram live session that
was reposted on twitter
she read the inappropriate comments she
was receiving out loud and made it clear
they were making her uncomfortable
she told viewers i am not consenting to
any of this
i do not want any of this at t has
expressed their support for the actress
saying we will not tolerate the
inappropriate comments and harassment of
milana vine troop
the talented actor and director who
portrays lily in our ads
last summer we disabled or deleted these
comments on our social sites
we continue to fight to support her and
our values
which appreciate and respect all women
the company has since released another
ad
featuring lily once again seated behind
a desk
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus
even more looper videos about your
favorite tv shows
and movies are coming soon subscribe to
our youtube channel and hit the bell
so you don't miss a single one